mãe do pobre ela vai fazendo você se
sentir culpado cada vez mais ela sabe da
mentira Qual foi a mentira quebrou um
prato ela perguntar PR você que você
quebrou o prato você falar que não e
depois ela encontra os cacos do prato
ela não chega PR você com os cacos na
mão e fala assim ó tu quebrou o prato
não quebrou o in não ela vai rodeando a
mentira para fazer a gente se sentir
mais culpado lez aquele prato que tinha
aqui tô sentindo uma falta eu não foi
não quei prato não Ó mãe interessante né
que só tinha tu em casa quando quebrou o
prato não foi eu mãe não foi eu que
quebrei o prato não hum
interessante e esse Caco aqui gleo é é
de qual prato mesmo gleon mamãe aí foi
foi por cara que eu quebrou o prato GS